why do I know I know it was another
night of protest and rioting as
demonstrators lit fires and confronted
the police in the place de la Concourse
this Fury here and across France at
president macron's plan to raise the
retirement age from 62 to 64. though
Henry because even if we're protest they
will just do a 49.3 and there is no
difference between a special
constitutional power yes yes and it's
only here in France so it's very hungry
you feel it's anti-democratic yes
[Music]
already in the streets pacifically and
they don't want to hear us and now we're
going to scream
[Applause]
[Music]
the nation is now braced for much more
of this protesters once again lobbing
missiles at the police
the backdrop to this standoff the lower
house of parliament which the government
bypassed instead using special
Constitutional Powers to force through
the legislation it is difficult to
overstate just how angry people are at
president macron's pension reforms the
big question now is whether or not the
strikes the demonstrations and even the
riots become more frequent in the days
weeks and months to come and bring
paralysis to this country France has
been dealing with rolling strikes and
direct actions for a couple of months
since the plan was announced and perhaps
nothing symbolizes this crisis more than
the bags of uncollected rubbish clogging
up the capital streets